[Musique]
bonjour à tous seraient ils vont trouver
cet après midi pour suivre les travaux
du sénat je vous propose de suivre une
audition du défenseur des droits jacques
toubon sur l'électro nisme ou
l'illettrisme numérique c'est-à-dire
l'inhabilité face aux outils
informatiques
un phénomène qui concerne 17 % de la
population française vous laisse écouter
cette audition de la vie économique et
sociale
quel serait selon vous monsieur le
défenseur des droits les conditions de
l'inclusion numérique
voilà mes premières questions
après ce propos introductif je laisserai
la parole d'un autre excellent
rapporteur notre collègue raymond vall
pour qu'ils vous posera son calcul
question tuer les membres de la mission
d'information également monsieur le
défenseur de droits vous avez la parole
monsieur le président je vous remercie
je remercie la mission de m'entendre
cet après midi au début d'ailleurs de
ces travaux puisque j'ai lu que vous
avez commencé à mettre au point votre
programme dans la semaine du 13 mai et
je suis très sensible au fait que vous
preniez en considération le travail que
nous avons fait depuis des années sur ce
sujet je vais naturellement consacré mon
exposé liminaire à faire état de notre
expérience de nos constatations de nos
recommandations ni en développant aux
trois lignes la première idée c'est que
la dématérialisation des services
publics puisque je rappelle que
l'essentiel de ma mission c'est la
relation les droits fondamentaux dans la
relation entre usagers et services
publics
la dématérialisation des services
publics doit être réalisé dans des
conditions qui permettent à toutes les
personnes
notamment les plus démunis d'accéder aux
services publics c'est à dire dans notre
pays en france d'accéder à leurs droits
la deuxième ligne ziehm le deuxième
point important dans ce que je vais dire
les besoins spécifiques de certains
publics doivent faire l'objet d'une
attention toute particulière de la part
des pouvoirs publics
et ceci est d'une certaine façon une
question c'est le mot que vous employez
d'inclusion de manière à ne pas laisser
des minorités en quelque sorte est exclu
enfin troisième idée il convient de
faire en sorte que la dématérialisation
des services publics ne soient plus subi
mais qu'elle soit pensée et qu'on
construit avec les usagers et pour les
usa donc à travers ces trois points je
vais répondre à vos questions au fils de
mon exposé est naturellement comme ces
communes c'est convenu je répondrais de
par écrit aux questions 7 et 8 plus
longue et plus complexe parce que le
temps en très peu de temps de ne pouvoir
le faire dans le dans le détail alors la
question c'est pourquoi est-ce que le
défenseur des droits s'est intéressé à
cette question comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure en parlant du rapport
droits des enfants de 2012 devons
presser sur le mini police pourquoi nous
nous sommes intéressés depuis longtemps
à cette question parce que d'abord très
clair et c'est par sénat de la
république qui me dira le contraire que
les services publics sont de longue date
constitutif à la fois du lien social et
du lien entre nous et du lien qui unit
chacun à l'état
leur transformation numérique a été
c'est le terme employé transformation
numérique a été engagée à l'automne 2007
dans le cadre d'un programme officiel
gouvernemental qui s'appelle action
publique 2022 est naturellement à veut
dire que
forcément et le lien social entre nous
et le lien qui unit chacun d'entre nous
avec les services publics va s'en
trouver affectée j'avais en ce qui
concerne des enfants je le rappelle dans
mon rapport annuel droits de l'enfant de
il portait sur le droit à l'éducation
consacrer une partie aux écrans et
j'avais notamment mis en garde en le
disant en dessous de 3 ans il ne
faudrait pas il ne fallait pas exposer
les enfants systématiquement aux écrans
mais c'est surtout c'est surtout à
partir de la fin de 2010 est à partir de
novembre 2017 et est très précisément à
partir de la toussaint 2010 est que je
me suis trouvé en face de plusieurs
milliers de réclamations qui portait sur
le sujet de la dématérialisation de la
délivrance des permis de conduire et des
cartes grises qui avait été mise en
place à ce moment là même du jour au
lendemain la nuit au lendemain dans le
cadre d'un plan qui s'appelle que vous
connaissez pousse naturellement le plan
préfecture nouvelle génération lancé
bien des années auparavant et qui
consistait en fait alléger le poids des
préfecture et des sous-préfectures ces
milliers de réclamations
elles sont devenues le premier motif de
saisine de l'institution à l'époque mais
nous avons eu au même moment beaucoup de
difficultés aussi concernant la
dématérialisation
par exemple pour les prestations
sociales dans les relations avec les
caisses vieillesse ou avec les caisses
d'allocations familiales et des
difficultés pour les demandes de titres
de séjour ont les étrangers des
difficultés aussi pour à l'époque les
déclarations de revenus car on en était
pas encore naturellement à la situation
actuelle c'est-à-dire au prélèvement à
la source et donc le défenseur des
droits était devenu à ce moment là comme
une sorte d' observateur privilégié les
effets de la dématérialisation
des services publics et donc j'ai décidé
d'une part bien sûr de traiter toutes
ces réclamations voir tous les risques
de travailler avec le ministère de
l'intérieur avec indication à la
sécurité routière avec tous les services
qui était compétent pour faire en sorte
de d'arrêter le sinistre véritablement
kelt et la dématérialisation des titres
comme ici à nîmes être émises je
rappelle qu'à un certain moment où vous
savez tous il ya eu plusieurs centaines
de milliers de titres qui étaient
bloqués ce qui voulait dire dans les
succursales automobiles et voitures qui
ne pouvait pas être livrés parce que le
lait les marchands voiture n'arrivait
pas à voir les cartes grises dans les
sous-préfectures vous parler ou dans les
victoires
donc on a traité naturellement que ça et
puis j'ai pensé que cette question était
plus vaste et j'ai entamé une série
d'auditions auprès des différents
acteurs qu'ils soient des porteurs de
réforme de dématérialisation et
représentants d'associations qui
accompagnent les usagers notamment les
usagers les plus fragiles mais aussi des
représentants d'associations d'élus j'ai
travaillé avec la mf par exemple ou bien
entendu de services ministériels et
notamment avec le secrétariat d'état en
charge du numérique
mounir mahdjoubi à l'époque au
aujourd'hui et c'est comme ça qu
effectivement en janvier 2019
j'ai publié ce rapport sur
dématérialisation et inégalités d'accès
aux services publics par son titre même
il dit bien ce que ça veut dire
il dit que alors que nous tous le
principe républicain et tout l'état de
droit je dirais c'est l'égalité d'accès
aux services publics de chacun chacune
on introduit à travers la
dématérialisation des inégalités de fait
et de droit dans l'accès aux services
publics et donc dans l'accès au droit et
le parti est partagé par exemple aux
droits sociaux
mais bien entendu
mon point de départ ou sur toulon on ne
vous entend plus ce n'était pas de
dénoncer ce processus mon point de
départ et je pense que c'est la même
chose pour la mission ramener à laquelle
vous ce n'est pas de dénoncer ce
processus c'est de dire que si ce
processus respecte les principes et les
objectifs du service public sans laisser
personne de côté
à égalité il peut naturellement être
fondamentalement positif ont la qualité
du service rendu aux usagers et là
dessus je souhaite devant vous dissiper
tout malentendu
mon rapport de janvier 2019 n'étant
d'aucune façon
un réquisitoire contre la
dématérialisation des procédures
administratives et il faut pas s'y
tromper dans un contexte national de
réduction et de recul et services
publics de proximité et les sénateurs
qui représente les zones rurales ou semi
rural le savent mieux que personne
mais aussi ce qui représente les
quartiers périphériques de nos grandes
villes
donc dans ce contexte de réduction des
services publics de proximité sur
l'ensemble des territoires qui est une
évolution qui remonte à vingt ou trente
ans et qui n'est pas naturellement de de
ce quinquennat ou de ce gouvernement
la dématérialisation peut effectivement
constituer un levier d'amélioration de
l'accès de tous et de toutes
au droit c'est le cas par exemple et
caisses sociales qui ont réussi
notamment à traiter des volumes de plus
en plus grand de dossiers de demandes de
prestations de remboursement et en
procédant à la numérisation d'un certain
nombre de procédures donc on peut
incontestablement trouvé dans la
numérisation une simplification un accès
aux informations que l'on n'a pas
autrement
un accès aux documents administratifs et
il ya un vous connaissez l'observatoire
de la dématérialisation des
miss publique de l'état dans un document
publié la maintenant en avril 2020 93 %
des usagers interrogés sont satisfaits
du dispositif de changement d'adressé en
ligne ou de l'inscription dématérialisée
sur les listes électorales ce qui veut
bien dire donc ce sont des processus qui
au caire le public adhère alors bien
entendu
j'ajoute que le ce que publient
observatoire et auquel peut-être faut
que vous vous intéressiez est un peu
biaisé parce que il ne tient compte que
de l'avis des usagers qui ont effectué
des démarches en ligne
ce qui veut dire que tous les gens qui
sont dans des zones blanches où tous
ceux qui sont victimes de la fracture
numérique n'ont pas répondu mais cela
est en quête même si c'est pas 93%
ça veut quand même dire que il y à un
nouveau à de progrès et d'amélioration
de la relation entre services publics et
usagers dans la métallisation d'autre
part elle entendu la dématérialisation
elle permet de lutter contre le non
recours et d'améliorer qui est vous
savez et pelé sont menées à l'époque où
le rsa il n'y avait que 60 % des
personnes éligibles qui le réclament et
donc le non recours est une véritable
plaie dans l'accès aux droits
ça permet de lutter contre le non
recours d'améliorer donc la crl réel de
sacs à usage et leurs droits tout en
respectant leur dignité
sans oublier que la possibilité de
réaliser un certain nombre de démarches
administratives en ligne plutôt qu'un
guichet ou par téléphone
et naturellement une source économies
pour les administrations une source de
bénéfices pour les usagers et quand ils
sont rompus mais un inconnu au maniement
de l'outil informatique
parce que c'est un gain de temps c'est
un gain de transport naturellement on a
plus de déplacements
c'est un gain d'un tente au guichet de
simplification des
c'est dur qui ont souvent été opéré à
l'occasion de la mise en place d'un
service dématérialisé mais la crise
sanitaire comme est en train de vivre
nous venons de que nous ayons encore et
les mesures prises dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence montre à quel point
cela est vrai c'est à dire comment les
nouvelles technologies nous apporte des
solutions
mais comment ces solutions doivent vite
à la disposition de tous et c'est les
trois points que je voudrais essayer de
développer maintenant que la
dématérialisation d'abord doit être
réalisé dans les conditions qui
permettent à toutes les personnes et
notamment aux plus démunis d'accéder aux
services publics donc à leur roi
c'est clair que si la dématérialisation
ne correspond qu'à une approche
budgétaire et comptable c'est à dire
consistant à pallier à la disparition
d'un certain nombre de services publics
par mesure d'économie ça voudra dire une
déresponsabilisation des services
publics
un renvoi souvent sur la sphère
associative pour accompagner les usagers
ou visées sur le secteur privé pour
compenser les défaillances du service
public
évidemment ça c'est le contraire de la
république
la situation est la suivante à peu près
20% de la population à un accès limité
ou inexistant aux procédures
dématérialisées alors suivant les études
suivant les références ça va de 17-18 à
à 25 mai mais je dirais que globalement
c'est entre un cinquième et un quart de
la population française qui a qui
éprouvent des limites et donc le new
deal etc trop nisme est bien juste parce
que c'est une façon d'illettrisme face
au numérique qui une boum des limites
pour accéder à ces procédures et plus ou
pour utiliser
ces technologies il ya différentes
formes le limitation dans l'accès au
numérique
car il est évident que la complexité des
uns n'est pas la même que celle des
autres ou les difficultés des hommes ne
sont pas les mêmes que celles des autres
on dit et ce que je dis c'est ce que dit
le secrétaire d'état par exemple en
charge du numérique chez ricoh que 13
millions de personnes déclarent 13
millions déclarent avoir des difficultés
des usages avec le numérique et donc
risque de se retrouver en situation de
non recours vis-à-vis des services
publics et j'en prendrai deux exemples
qui peuvent paraître paradoxaux il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui manie les
smartphones à la perfection qui twitte
qui sont sur les réseaux sociaux en
permanence qui font des jeux qui
regardent des films des séries
télévisées
si vous leur donnez un formulaire en
ligne par exemple l'assurance pour
l'école ils sont incapables de le
remplir
parce que par exemple ils ont un
problème de langage ou de 2,2
configuration de ces de ces sites
administratifs qui ne leur conviennent
pas le vous avez des personnes âgées qui
sont parfaitement socialiser mais qui
pourtant sont peu attirés par le
numérique ou au contraire qui sont
socialement ou géographiquement isolés
mais qui sont actifs sur les réseaux
toutes les situations se retrouvent et
cela étant il ya une observation km fait
c'est que l'absence de connexion est
très élevé dans trois population que
sont les retraités les non diplômés et
ceux qui ont un faible revenu 40 % n'ont
pas de connexion parmi les personnes
ayant des bas revenus
54 % parmi les personnes qui n'ont aucun
diplôme et l'âge est aussi un facteur
discriminant
même si les inégalités se réduisent
ainsi le taux de connexion à internet
atteint seulement 57% chez les personnes
de 70 ans alors qu'il est de 85% au
l'ensemble de la population
donc voilà déjà un état global des
limites dans l'accès au numérique mais
il faut aussi ajouter les personnes qui
ne parlent pas français qui ne
maîtrisent pas le langage administratif
je parlais des jeunes tout à l'heure aux
personnes qui sont simplement en
situation d'illettrisme
vous savez que la journée de préparation
à la défense montre chaque année à quel
point ce taux qui est aux alentours de
10% est difficile à faire tomber ou ce
sont des personnes qui maîtrisent pas
l'outil informatique
et puis il ya des personnes qui savent
pas comment faire et qui souvent ont
besoin d'être accompagnés parce qu'elles
ont peur de se tromper
et comme vous savez beaucoup de sites
administratifs beaucoup de sites et
organismes sociaux si vous vous trompez
vous ne pouvez pas revenir en arrière
on ne pouvait pas corrigé et c'est une
c'est d'ailleurs une des améliorations
qu'il va falloir installer c'est la
possibilité de toujours reprendre ses
propres erreurs
bien entendu il y à aussi c'est ce que
j'ai souligné dans mon rapport des
obstacles structurels à la
transformation numérique et ne serait-ce
qu' il faut avoir une connexion internet
de qualité
le débit nécessaire pour réaliser une
démarche administrative est estimé entre
et 8 mégabits par seconde et donc on
peut par exemple disposer d'un accès
adsl qu'on a depuis très longtemps et ne
pas être en mesure d'avoir une connexion
internet suffisante pour réaliser une
démarche en ligne
il ya donc des zones que vous tous
blanches grises qui entravent l'accès
limite de 2 des personnes alors eu droit
et là il ya des données territoriales le
jeu je les énumère mais je pense que
naturellement la mission les prendre en
les a prises en compte immédiatement 0 7
% des français n'ont pas accès à une
connexion internet fixe non pas parce
qu'il n'y a pas cent mille personnes
sont en et capacité d'accéder au réseau
dans les communes de moins de 1000
habitants
plus d'un tiers des habitants n'ont pas
accès à internet de qualité c'est-à-dire
75 % des communes de france et 15% de la
population
c'est pas l'épaisseur du trait c'est une
situation qui est ma cible 19 % des
français n'ont pas d'ordinateur à
domicile et 27% d'entre eux n'ont pas de
smartphone donc les les équipements ce
conte un des problèmes d'ailleurs
j'ajoute que dans beaucoup de procédures
il ne faut pas seulement un ordinateur
mais il faut aussi un scanner pour
réaliser les procédures et envoyer les
pièces dans les démarches
administratives et beaucoup de personnes
peuvent avoir leur est pas et pas
l'autre
deuxième élément dans ces inégalités
c'est l'inégalité territoriale qui c'est
qui s'exprime non seulement à
l'intérieur de l'hexagone
mais entre l'hexagone et les territoires
ultramarins et j'ai eu l'occasion devant
vous au sénat plusieurs fois de parler
avec des sénateurs qui représente
l'outre-mer et
ont partagé les constatations que je
fais les ménages d'outre-mer n'ont pas
bénéficié contrairement aux ménages
métropolitains du développement des
offres de forfaits à prix low cost et de
la baisse des prix qui a suivi les
écarts de prix
un quart du prix des abonnements
concernant les services de téléphonie
mobile ont augmenté même entre deux
ministres 2010 et 2015
ils sont dans certains départements
d'outre-mer de 40% au dessus d'eux et
tarifs de la métropole donc on voit bien
que là il ya un véritable traitement
différencié dans l'accès à l'internet et
dans l'accès aux services publics
et c'est vrai l'outre-mer c'est vrai les
zones rurales et séverine pour les zones
urbaines et en outre-mer c'est en
particulièrement très vrai entre eux les
zones agglomérées et les zones
[Musique]
enfin le dernier point dans ses
constatations sur l'inégalité
l'expérience de la dématérialisation
montre et c'est là où les pouvoirs
publics et le parlement notamment ont je
pense eu une action à à conduire montre
que le problème réside également dans la
manière dont les administrations procède
dont les administrations se conduisent
si la démarche de dématérialisation
n'est pas accessible aux personnes en
situation de handicap
si elle est réalisée dans l'urgence
c'était un peu le cas de ce que j'ai dit
pour le png en novembre 2017 si elle
s'accompagne d'une fermeture radicale
des déchets physique si elle n'est pas
accompagnée
ça ne peut pas fonctionner et à ce
moment là de la dématérialisation
devient ce que j'ai dit dans mon rapport
un nouveau frein dans l'accès aux droits
des usagers et crée naturellement malgré
notamment par exemple la loi qui a été
votée
a besoin est ce que une nouvelle raison
de diminuer la confiance des usagers
envers le service public c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec le
plan préfecture nouvelle génération qui
à dématérialiser les cartes grises et
les permis de construire en basculant au
tout numérique
du jour au lendemain le soir du 6
novembre
le lendemain le set terminé et qui a
fermé les dix chez le son du jour au
lendemain donc j'ai observé tous les
tous les cas de la manière dont les
administrations peuvent se conduire et
les défauts qui peuvent exister dans la
mise en oeuvre des procédures
dématérialisées l'absence de tests
suffisant pour vérifier le
fonctionnement au préalable du logiciel
l'absence d'associations des usagers au
processus de construction du service des
mises en service rapide et sans mise en
place le dispositif d'accueil ou de
traitements alternatifs c'est ce que je
viens de dire
pour compenser d'éventuels mauvais
fonctionnement des logiciels
vous savez qu'en plus pour les cartes
grises et le et le le permis de conduire
naturellement les services de l'état ont
joué de malchance puisque il ya eu un
bug en plus de pays et difficultés sur
la procédure elle-même
j'ai constaté aussi l'absence de
réflexion sur l'ergonomie des sites
parfois même sur leurs fonctionnalités
la manière dont les administrations
conduisent leurs projets les
investissements qui sont consentis ou
non pour mettre en place de nouvelles
procédures sont naturellement
déterminant c'est de la responsabilité
et des services publics et les
administrations d'organiser la
continuité et la qualité du service
par exemple quand on propose des rendez
vous uniquement en ligne
pour les démarches relatives au droit au
séjour des étrangers
puis quand on prévoit sur le site
on doit prendre le rendez-vous un nombre
de rendez vous très largement
insuffisant ça a conduit au fait que ces
personnes
ils veulent entrer dans le système d'une
préfecture pour demander un titre de
séjour ne peuvent pas le faire et qui
sont carrément privés de leurs droits
vous savez que c'est la situation qui
perdure encore aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre par exemple de grosses
préfecture de la région parisien je dois
dire pour terminer sur ce point qu'il y
à une prise de conscience du côté des
pouvoirs publics de ces nécessités de la
transformation numérique
j'en prendrais un exemple très précis il
y a eu vous le savez au mois de janvier
la conférence nationale du handicap
comme tous les deux ans sous la
présidence du président de la république
et à cette occasion le secrétaire d'état
chargé du numérique c'est le ricoh a
fait une déclaration
c'est là notamment qu'il a dit qu'il y
avait 13 millions de personnes qui
étaient en difficulté
il a reconnu ce que je vais vous dire
c'est à dire que la quasi totalité des
sites de l'administration ne sont pas
accessibles
encore aujourd'hui à beaucoup de
personnes porteuses de handicap et s'est
engagé à ce que je sois une des
priorités de son action
je je je suis fait moins prêts à lui
faire grâce rove au gouvernement de ses
intentions car je crois que le
gouvernement l'état mais aussi les
collectivités territoriales et les
grands services publics notamment et
droits sociaux de la protection sociale
ont bien compris que on ne pourrait pas
mettre en oeuvre la numérisation en
laissant de côté des millions et des
millions de
personne justement c'est mon deuxième
point les besoins spécifiques de
certains publics qui doivent faire
l'objet d'une attention particulière et
je vienne parlais à l'instant avec la
déclaration de cédric haut à la cnh et
personnes handicapées
c'est ces publics dont je veux parler
c'est les personnes porteuses de
handicap
les majeurs protégés et les détenus
alors la crise sanitaire le virus sascoc
2 qui a été un formidable révélateur
naturellement on on perd a permis de
constater le caractère stratégique de
l'accès numérique des services publics
pour les citoyens nous avons fonctionné
comme ça depuis le 16 mars et la
continuité du service
les liens ont été maintenus entre
personnes entre les pouvoirs publics et
les citoyens
depuis que manières possibles et on
s'est bien rendu compte de ce que
c'était si on n'avait pas été dans cet
état de technologies beaucoup de choses
naturellement n'aurait pas pu être fait
mais cela étant on s'est aperçu aussi
que quand on est privé d'internet à
peine on n'a pas de compte bancaire
c'est plus de 500 mille personnes en
france n'ont pas de compte bancaire et
que les deux tiers des bureaux de poste
sont fermés comment on fait au début du
mois d'avril pour aller toucher son rsa
on ne peut en l'occurrence si on fait
partie de ces personnes touchées qu'en
espèces et nous avons à la fin de mars
notamment soulevé cette question nous
avons travaillé avec la poste les
beaucoup de bureaux ont réouvert à cette
occasion et comme vous savez de manière
générale les la location de les
allocations non contributives au début
du mois d'avril ont été
distribuée de manière assez correct on
inclut naturellement de queue mais
c'était normal c'était les mesures de
distanciation et mais c'est bien la
démonstration que il y a là une limite
dans le dans l'utilisation du numérique
de la même façon comment une personne
aveugle ou une personne avec un handicap
cognitif pouvait-elle se débrouiller
avec les attestations dans les premiers
temps du compliment les attestations
dérogatoire dans les premiers temps du
confinement
on a eu des personnes pur été verbalisés
verbalisé parce que on n'a pas voulu
tenir compte du fait que pour elle les
attestations qu'il fallait remplir
n'était pas accessible que pour
certaines personnes
elle était incompréhensible et on a bien
vu que on pouvait le faire si on voulait
faire le ministère de l'intérieur a
écouté les associations et nous qui
avons soulevé cette question et en
quelques jours
le ministère a rendu les attestations de
déplacement dérogatoire accessible par
exemple en les traduisant en langage
facile et à comprendre
valcke c'est donc possible même si pour
le nez confinement j'ai été de nouveau
obligé de saisir le ministère de
l'intérieur pour les attestations qu'il
faut aujourd'hui remplir pour la sortie
de confinement notamment pour pour aller
travailler ou pour aller à certains
rendez vous médicaux pour certains
déplacements mais ça traduit en fait une
réalité qui est au delà de la crise
sanitaire
la réalité permanente que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure le taux d'accessibilité
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap des sites publics est d'à peu
près 5 %
et évidemment ça veut donc dire que des
millions de personnes seraient où sont
écartés de la transformation numérique
de l'état ou des collectivités
territoriales d'ailleurs c'est la même
chose
il est donc indispensable de travailler
sur la dématérialisation que nous avons
devant nous dans le cadre de l'agenda
2022 mais sur la dématérialisation de ce
qui a déjà été fait ce qui veut dire que
les 95% de sites publics qui sont peu ou
pas accessible doivent faire l'objet
d'un plan volontariste de mise à niveau
et c'est ce à quoi s'est engagé cedrico
au cours de cette conférence nationale
du handicap dont je parlais tout à
l'heure je rappelle à ce sujet que on
n'est pas dans 2 on n'est pas dans le
dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
humanitaire ou le compassionnel
il existe une convention internationale
des droits des personnes handicapées qui
fait de l'accessibilité une condition
préalable essentielle de la jouissance
effective par les personnes handicapées
sur la base de l'égalité des droits
civils politiques économiques sociaux et
culturels et d'autres lois à nous du 11
février 2005 qui est d'ailleurs la
grande loi sur le handicap est
antérieure à la convention
internationale de 2010 qui a d'ailleurs
été modifié depuis par la loi du 5
septembre 2018
elle a introduit une obligation
d'accessibilité des services de
communication au public en ligne mais
organismes du secteur public
malheureusement cette obligation ne
comporte aucune sanction
et c'est comme ça que la situation
aujourd'hui est encore extrêmement
mauvaises comme je viens de le dire il
n'y a pas de sanction du non respect des
règles d'accessibilité
il ya une amende qui porte
qui ne porte pas sur le défaut
d'accessibilité des sites en tant que
tel mais sur la publication ou pas sur
le site de la mention de la conformité
ou de l'absence de conformité
c'est un peu vous savez comme c'est le
panneau on voit les permis de construire
qui sont affichés et où on écrit dessus
toute une série de choses et puis sur le
chantier derrière les personnes qui font
les travaux font des choses qui n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec ce qui est
inscrit sur la fiche est bien là vous
êtes pénalisé uniquement parce que vous
n'avez pas mis que le site est conforme
ou pas conformes même pas du tout parce
qu'il n'est pas accessible
donc je le dis c'est 1,1 point peut-être
principaux pour vous pour votre mission
si l'on veut véritablement qu' il y ait
un accès large qu'on lutte contre ces
petits électro nice mme comme inclus on
savait très bien qu'en matière de
personnes handicapées
la politique c'est la politique
d'inclusion qu'il y ait donc une
politique d'inclusion ma cible il faut
absolument que les règles
d'accessibilité des sites publics soient
assorties de sanctions dissuasives
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas respectés s'ils
ont des majeurs protégés n'est pas prise
en compte non plus dans les processus de
dématérialisation des démarches e
administratif alors eu alors plomb les
nouvelles technologies l'ong le sait
sont un des moyens de favoriser la
participation pleine et effective et
majeurs protégés et notamment des
personnes âgées dépendantes à la société
le le cadre le leem les mesures de
protection
actuellement en vigueur les contraintes
rencontrées par les mandataires
judiciaires risquent en fait aujourd'hui
de freiner voire d'anéantir les
principes et les droits consacrés par la
sienne et ph et qui ont été dans la loi
justice que le gouvernement
adoptée l'année dernière largement
réaffirmé et notamment la possibilité du
mariage possibilités du pacs le droit de
vote pour les personnes majeures
protégées qui ont été très largement
étendue
en fait on a deux problèmes c'est que il
n'y a pas de possibilités sur les sites
de démarches en ligne 2 d'accès
spécifique pour le tuteur du majeur est
donc ce dernier est contraint d'utiliser
les identifiants personnels du majeur
protégé dont il est le tuteur et donc
qu'ils excluent de fait puisque c'est
lui qui le fait et pas l'autre qu'il
peut le faire de la démarche
administrative
or tout le principe de la convention
internationale des droits de la personne
handicapée et le piercing de l'inclusion
c'est qu'on ne doit pas se substituer
aux majeurs protégés n'auront doit
l'accompagner dans l'activité qui doit
pouvoir essayer de faire lui-même et il
ya en fait une réalité bien entendu
entre les majors protéger les autres
d'usagé c'est la même chose pour les
mandataires judiciaires qui sont garants
l'autonomie est majeur protégé très peu
de sites internet des services publics
prévoit la possibilité pour les tiers
mandataire de réaliser les démarches
administratives courantes du majeur
protégé en leur qualité de professionnel
en charge de la protection juridique
donc là aussi je voudrais qu'on
généralise pour tous les services
publics le double accès aux comptes
personnels
le pour la personne majeure protégée et
l'autre pour le mandataire judiciaire
adaptée à chaque e en bas et d'ailleurs
dans la même ligne j'aime proposer et je
l'avais proposé au moment justement de
la loi de programme sur la justice la
création d'un identifiant unique pour
accéder l'ensemble des services publics
dématérialisés
il y actuellement vous le savez
l'émission ait un débat à l'assemblée
nationale sur l'identifiant sur
l'identité numérique et je vais
prochainement être entendu d'ailleurs à
ce sujet et je pense que la question de
l'identifiant unique est une question
qu'il faut se poser enfin la dernière
catégorie qui pose des problèmes se sont
naturellement les détenus pour un détenu
comme vous le savez je pense que ce
principe est évident la seule chose dont
ils sont privés c'est la liberté
tous les autres tous leurs autres droits
ils s'en réjouissent
sauf ceux qui à titre de peine
complémentaire peuvent être privés de
leurs droits civiques ou ou depuis droit
d'exercer cette profession
mais de manière générale seule la
liberté d'aller et de venir est enlevée
aux personnes qui sont détenues
tous les autres droits ils doivent
pouvoir les faire valoir
or beaucoup de démarches administratives
nécessite de remplir des formulaires
dématérialisée et ça veut dire
le détenu doit être nécessairement
accompagnée par un tiers puisqu'il ne
peut pas accéder de manière autonome à
ces formulaires dématérialisée en fait
en pratique ce sont les simples et ces
pays
les conseillers et ses ip les
conseillers d'insertion et de probation
crealys toutes ces démarches
en fait leur charge de travail ne leur
permet pas de faire face à ça pour tous
les détenus
les difficultés sont aussi accentuées
pour les détenus qui sont condamnés à
des peines de très courte durée et en
fait on peut pas pendant dix ans dans le
temps très court où ils sont détenus
mettre en place le suivi par les
services d'insertion et donc que les
droits peuvent par exemple s'éteindre
pendant qu'ils sont emprisonnés
il faut qu'on mette en place une
véritable politique de partenariats ou
niveau national entre l'administration
pénitentiaire les différents organismes
sociaux comme cela existe déjà avec pôle
emploi et que ce ne soit pas qu'on ne le
fasse pas seulement au niveau local
entre tels centres de détention est et
tel ou tel service paie que ce soit une
véritable politique nationale
les de ce point de vue il est évident
que il faut qu'on trouve un moyen de
résoudre la contradiction dans laquelle
sonné il ya une circulaire du 13 octobre
2009 qui est leur relative à l'accès à
l'informatique pour les personnes
placées sous main de justice
elle interdit l'accès à l'internet et à
s'y limitent l'accès des détenus à leur
droit donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on
étudie la possibilité pour que ces
détenus puissent accéder au site
internet des services publics pas où
l'internet par des jeux se met au site
internet des services publics des
organismes sociaux et aux sites de
formation en ligne reconnus par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale je
pense que c'est extrêmement important
notamment pour les détenus qui sont là
sont jeunes et qu'ils sont là pendant un
certain temps et qui doivent assurer
leur formation
je rappelle que dans le code pénal il ya
une obligation d'insertion et de
réinsertion du détenu
c'est l'article 130 1 du code pénal
ce serait une manière de réaliser cette
obligation dans les partenariats qui
n'existe pas ou qui n'existe plus et qui
serait nécessaire je me prends un
exemple c'est la carte d'identité
en fait il y a
il y avait des procédures qui faisait
que le ministère de l'intérieur assuré
la possi
militer d'aller faire les formalités
pour faire renouveler une carte
d'identité ou pour faire une carte
d'identité à une personne détenue à
l'intérieur de la détention
et aujourd'hui ces procédures comme vous
savez pour la ceni sont dématérialisés
et beaucoup de détenus n'ont plus la
possibilité de se voir délivrer ou
renouveler une carte d'identité en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe le détenu doit
faire une pré demande en ligne puis en
principe deux déplacements en mairie et
dont chaque fois une autorisation de
sortie donné par le juge pour se faire
délivrer ça j'ai saisi il ya encore
quelques temps
pendant la période de confinement
d'ailleurs j'ai saisi le ministre de
l'intérieur on établisse une procédure
qui soit plus accessible pour l'instant
ça n'a pas encore été fait j'ai aussi
dans la politique d'inclusion qui sort
des détenus j'ai aussi fait la
proposition d'un dispositif de coffre
fort numérique qui permettrait à aux
détenus quand ils entrent en détention
de détenir dans sur ce compte sorte
l'ensemble des pièces justificatives
pour une demande de papier à à nice tu
veux il y a aussi une difficulté c'est
que certaines démarches administratives
exigent un paiement un paiement en ligne
et il faudrait donc que ses obligations
de paiement imposé par la réglementation
connaissent des exceptions et que une
autre modalité de paiement puisse être
mise à la disposition des détenus autre
que l'utilisation d'un compte bancaire
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
cinq cent mille personnes aujourd'hui
selon la banque de france selon son
rapport sur l'inclusion bancaire de 2017
ne disposent pas de compte bancaire
donc ce que je voudrais dire pour
conclure sur ces publics particuliers et
défavorisées
c'est que il faut absolument que ce que
nous voyons à travers l'urgence
sanitaire est ce que nous avons vu
depuis des années dans la transformation
des conditions d'accès aux services
publics est aujourd'hui exacerbée par le
fait que nous sommes confinés doivent
inciter l'ensemble des acteurs publics à
adapter et améliorer les services
numériques qu'il existe ou qui se met en
place la transformation de l'état
l'évolution des services publics
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs doit
impérativement tenir compte de la
situation réelle des usagers et de tous
les usagers enfin je terminerai en
disant troisième idée qu'il faut faire
en sorte que la dématérialisation des
services publics ne soient plus subi
mais qu'elle soit pensée et co
construite avec les usagers et pour les
usagers
il faut que les le que les initiatives
privées ou publiques qui existent et qui
accompagne les personnes dans l'accès
aux procédures dématérialisées montre
que ça fonctionne mais ça ne peut pas
résoudre les difficultés de millions de
personnes
il faut que pour chacun chacune d'entre
nous les politiques d'accompagnement et
pouvoirs publics soit ambitieuse
cohérente structurantes
autrement dit que l'investissement que
l'on fait pour la transformation
numérique ils soient également fait à la
même hauteur
pour l'accompagnement des usagers
et c'est vrai que ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et que si on continue la
dématérialisation au rythme où elle se
fait aujourd'hui
sans cet accompagnement à due
concurrence en quelque sorte on risque
de voir les écarts et les inégalités se
creuser davantage
une des réponses et je pense que c'est
un des sujets votre mission va
naturellement traité ce et les
formations ou numériques qui ont été
prévus dans le programme pour un
numérique inclusive qui a été adoptée
l'année dernière
là dessus il ya quelques des photos même
parce que souvent c'est pour mation sont
assurés par des volontaires en service
civique ou par des bénévoles qui sont
donc des personnes engagées sur une
durée relativement courte il ya donc un
roulement important qu'il peu propice à
la continuité du service public et à la
à la profonde y semant des capacité
d'accompagner notamment de ces jeunes du
volontaire suite de développer un
service mais je peux en parler parce que
quand il ya eu la sphère des cartes
grises et du permis de conduire le
ministre de l'intérieur pour faire face
aux difficultés avaient mis en place des
points d'accès numérique et qui étaient
dans les préfectures et les
sous-préfectures et il était le plus
souvent tenus par des volontaires du
service civique et ses points d'accès
aux nôtres lui résolu quelques
difficultés mais n'ont pas naturellement
jouer le rôle d'accompagnement
tu aurais été nécessaire
l'accompagnement doit être fait par des
professionnels formés au numérique et au
travail social c'est pour cela que je
recommande notamment l'organisation d'un
test d'évaluation des apprentissages
fondamentaux de l'usaj de numérique à
l'occasion de la journée défense et
citoyenneté nôtre
période période qui s'est ouverte au
mois de mars du confinement a
soudainement exacerbée des inégalités
face au monde numérique et notamment
parce que les lieux d'accompagnement ont
été pour la plupart fermés ces lieux où
les personnes éloignées du numérique ou
en difficulté vont pour faire leurs
démarches
les délégués de défenseur des droits qui
se sont tous arrêtés de fonctionner en
présentiel
ils ont continué à fonctionner notamment
en virtuel les écrivains publics les
associations d'entr'aide les centres
communaux d'action sociale et certaines
personnes se sont trouvées et cas dans
l'impossibilité matérielle d'accéder aux
à leurs droits ou de comprendre les
consignes mises en place pendant cette
période et l'accès des donc simplement à
un ordinateur pour réaliser leurs
démarches
je pense que cette période a montré
toute l'importance non seulement de
l'accompagnement mais de la médiation et
je mets beaucoup d'espoir pour ma part
je pense beau si l'un des messieurs les
sénateurs dans le nouveau dispositif
france service qui a été lancé l'année
dernière et qui prend la suite des
maisons de services au public et qui
semble vouloir répondre à l'enjeu et
difficultés d'accès aux services publics
d'une partie de la population le jugera
naturellement sur les résultats obtenus
mais moi je tiens beaucoup à rappeler
deux embouts que au moment de la loi
évoque en particulier
j'ai de nouveau défendu une disposition
législative au sein de code entre des
relations entre les usagers et
l'administration imposant de préserver
plusieurs modalités d'accès aux services
publics
pour conques une démarche administrative
ne soit accessible uniquement par voie
dématérialisée et cette question reste
naturellement d'actualité mais cela
étant comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
beaucoup reste à faire si on veut que la
dématérialisation des services publics
soient réalisés dans des conditions qui
permettent à toutes les personnes
d'accéder aux services publics donc à
leurs droits et ne soit plus subi mais
qu'elle soit pensée et construite avec
les usagers et pour les usagers et cela
est possible nous en avons un exemple
qui est un exemple anecdotique du tout
c'est la réforme la primitivité qui a
été fait en 2016 la nouvelle prime
d'activité était attribuée exclusivement
en ligne
90% des éligibles sont allés la toucher
mais pourquoi parce qu'au moins un tiers
des personnes ont été accompagnées par
des agents pôle emploi où des quais
c'est là que sont familiales pour
réaliser les demandes en ligne
et c'est exactement la démonstration de
ce que la dématérialisation est efficace
excellente pour tous si on prend le
muscle d'accompagnement si on considère
qu' on peut faire de dématérialisation
si je rejoins demi ainsi uniquement pour
eux les csp + où les accros de
l'informatique
il est absolument évident que la
dématérialisation va creuser des
inégalités qui sont déjà un des écueils
naturellement des procédures en papier
c'est évident il faut intégrer dans la
réalisation de toutes les réformes c'est
le joint d'accompagnement expliciter les
mesures pour 10,6 terre il faut
consacrer
tif estiment les économistes et risation
à ce processus d'accompagnement
je crois que la vraie solution c'est
naturellement au bout du compte que l'on
conserve plusieurs modalités d'accès des
modalités d'accès multiples aux services
publics pour qu' il y ait un accès pour
toutes et pour tous aux services publics
tous témoignent d'une prise de
conscience mais quelles seront leurs
conséquences concrètes pour la
population et à quelle échéance
pour ma part je pense que les mesures
les plus simples et structurante sont
tout simplement que l'usager ne doit pas
être confronté à un canal unique matin
matérialiser la possibilité doit
demeurer de réaliser des formalités
autrement qu'en numérique et donc et
donc par rapport à l'agenda 22 qui n'est
pas si éloignée ça fait un an et demi
devant nous que les démarches
administratives dématérialisée doivent
demeurer à culte est une possibilité et
non pas devenir une obligation
voilà ce que je voudrais vous voyez
comme nous l'avons technique ou d'une
question organisation administrative
c'est en fait l'état de droit qui est en
cause et la cohésion sociale dans nos
tripes
merci monsieur le président pour chose
rassure complet précis et circonstanciés
on voit que ce sujet vous le maîtriser
pleinement mais j'ai des collègues qui
souhaite vous poser des questions et je
commence comme le jeu le indiqué tout à
l'heure par céder la parole à monsieur
raymond vall notre rapporteur
merci de ces brillants merci monsieur
jacques toubon en danger vraiment quelle
densité dans ce rapport
dans ces chiffres dans cette
sensibilisation à un sujet certes
important mais dont la pandémie a été un
révélateur extraordinaire en quelque
sorte vous avez souligne également
oui c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai écouté avec
passion et beaucoup d'intérêt tout ce
que vous avez dit élue d'un territoire
rural
je peux vous dire que j'ai sur bien des
passages étaient très satisfaits que
vous parliez d'inégalités territoriales
de l'état l'axé sentiment d'abandon qui
s'est creusé avec cette accélération du
numérique
donc moi je je je veux pas monopoliser
la parole j'avais prévu un tas de
questions mais vous avez répondu et
finalement parce que votre exposé est
excellent et je crois qu'avec votre
explosion pourrait faire une grande
partie de notre constat mais j'ai retenu
également que évidemment la
mondialisation de l'économie
l'accélération de l'innovation la part
de ses grands monopoles pour vendre des
produits qui ont une durée de vie très
courte fait que on s'est retrouvé dans
une situation où vous l'avez souligné il
n'y a pas eu d'accompagnement de cette
grande mutation numérique et c'est là le
fond du sujet on a on a eu à des moments
à lutter contre l'illettrisme vous
l'avez aussi appelé et c'est vrai que
n'a pas fait une chose pour eux les
lectures nice manque quelque chose pour
aller très vite
et la question que vous me posez c'est
est un peu de votre avis sur la
politique qui a été développée depuis
2008 pour lutter contre cette
électronique mais vous savez également
beaucoup plu mais j'aimerais quand même
que vous puissiez nous en parler un
petit peu du constat que vous pourrez
faire à votre niveau parce que vous êtes
non aujourd'hui certainement confronté
qu'on voulait souligner un certain
passage pour le permis de conduire et
les cartes grises à peut-être beaucoup
de réclamations
j'ajouterai que moi je suis révolté par
le fait que dans un territoire rural
les opérateurs ont fait en quelque sorte
un efforts certes pour amener
l'infrastructure numérique mais à quel
prix
à quel prix je suis révolté par le fait
que l'opérateur puis se raccorder y
compris dans les territoires ruraux des
territoires comme une mise entre
parenthèses rentable elias les autres
d'être obligé de faire les mesures et
questembert penser que tous ces
opérateurs en particulier ceux qu'on a
faits historiques ont bien eu des
infrastructures initiale qu'ont été
payés par les citoyens et donc on a
démarré avec une infrastructure qui a
été gratuitement mises à leur
disposition
et lorsqu'il a fallu le mettre à un
certain niveau le faire évoluer et
passer à ce numérique
je trouve que politiquement et je ne
m'exclus pas de la responsabilité
nous avons été très mauvais très mauvais
c'est scandaleux
la ruralité en particulier dans ce
problème de 2,2 numérique et est tabou
parce que hélas du et elle a dû apporter
sa contribution pour des routes pour des
autoroutes pour des voies ferrées qui
ont d'ailleurs la plupart des cas
disparu et il a fallu en plus qu'elles
apportent leur contribution d'une
manière importante environ entre 45 50 %
si je prends le cas du département du
gers ça va coûter environ 90 millions 90
millions pour désenclaver le département
ce département au potentiel fiscal très
pauvre va payer 45 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir avoir un accès sans aucune
chance qu'un accompagnement de ces
opérateurs ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur la formation le minimum de
formation
bon c'est vrai que nous sommes
aujourd'hui après quelques auditions
nous sommes évidemment en mesure de voir
que cette mission a été très pertinente
supra kona elle arrive au bon moment
on a été déposée mois de janvier nous
n'avions pas ce moment-là pris la
dimension de la pandémie mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui avec tout ce que vous
avez rapporté que nous savions déjà
nous avons je crois un autre rôle à
jouer de prise de conscience nous avons
notre rôle à jouer de force de
proposition pour savoir comment on
accélère et on donne des moyens et on
doit aussi une impulsion politique pour
rattraper donc ces populations vous avez
cité le chiffre d'environ 14 millions de
français
et si vous aussi vous en tenez aux
critères développés par l'insee c'est
presque 45% de la population française
qui à des degrés moindres est concerné
par ce problème
comment ne pas donc aujourd'hui en
prendre conscience
et quand on voit en face après les
premières auditions qu'on a fait les
faibles moyens que tu été mise en place
on c'est vrai que il faut absolument
réagir et je crois que vous nous avez
donné une très bonne impulsion pour le
faire et je tenais à vous en remercier
chercheur se leurrer pongistes d'un mot
parce que voulons la politique qui a été
conduite jusqu'à maintenant deux points
de clics et celui de votre mission
est ce une politique naturellement
qu'ils étaient insuffisantes
et encore une fois j'aurais faire
simplement est ce que le propre
secrétaire d'état au numérique série
coady ou que la conférence nationale du
handicap au mois de janvier ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est lui qui est qui qui
l'a dit donc il ya un effort très
important à faire et il y a surtout il
faut un changement de paradigme
il faut que toutes ces opérations de
transformation soit fait en intégrant
l'usagé ultime dès le début par la
construction et la configuration du
système il faut dès le début se demander
comment dans le gers
comment
dans les hauts-de-seine comment ce
monsieur ou celle d'à côté l'âge où de
telles conditions pourra utiliser le
système que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place qui a toutes les
qualités intrinsèques mais il faut se
poser la question est ce qu'il va
pouvoir être utilisé par tout le monde
et par chacune et par chacun c'est
exactement la question il faut le mettre
au début de tout projet à qui s'adresse
et comment les gens vont pouvoir
l'utiliser
merci je propose à présent de passer la
parole successivement à eric gold
pascale gruny à viviane artigalas et
martin berthet je fais observer que
certains de nos collègues quant aux
contrats de le quitter vers 17 heures et
donc je demanderai à chacun s'il est
possible de s'exprimer et manière
conseiller dit merci président bonjour
monsieur toubon alors en matière
numérique
on mesure bien celle de ceux qui sont
mal desservis par les réseaux aussi bien
à mesure et ceux qui n'ont pas le
matériel informatique suffisant on peut
aussi bien mesuré celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas le savoir faire de base
par contre on s'intéresse moins à celles
et ceux qui n'utilisent pas les moyens
informatiques de peur de se tromper les
applications logicielles sont
aujourd'hui conçu pour un public
d'initiés
vous disiez tout à l'heure un devoir de
personnes expérimentées et ne montre
aucune bienveillance avec les personnes
les plus fragiles vous avez marqué ce
n'est plus fragiles évidemment les non
diplômés les bienvenus les personnes
âgées c'est cela que on remarque aussi
de mise en confiance des utilisateurs y
compris lorsqu'on navigue sur des sites
institutionnels
souvent ces sites sont anxiogènes pour
le plus fragile et pour vous donc
j'aimerais savoir quels sont les
accompagnements qui font défaut et
sommes nous assez exigeant avec les
concepteurs de logiciels ou les donneurs
d'ordre en termes d'inclusion numérique
puisque la dépénalisation et maintenant
service public et puis pensez vous que
les maisons france services ou les mais
ça paie aux prétendues solutions
satisfaisantes pour les personnes de
plus écarté du numérique donc si vous
avez déjà répondu en partie à ces
questions mais je remercie d'assistant
quand tu veux je vous ferai une réponse
très précise
vous avez voté une loi qui s'appelle est
ce qu est cette loi pendant longtemps
vous vous en souvenez elle a été appelée
la loi sur le droit à l'erreur
parce qu'elle comporte une disposition
qui est qu' on est disons par exemple un
organisme social ne va plus considérés
comme nécessairement un fraudeur une
personne qui aura fait une erreur qui se
sera trompé de cases qui aidera il ne va
pas lui réclamer des indus il va y avoir
en quelque sorte une présomption de
bonne foi pour la personne qui s'est
trompé par exemple en remplissant un
formulaire électronique
eh bien c'est exactement de ça qu'il
s'agit
il faut à et j'ajoute que cette
disposition a été votée par la loi par
vous elle n'a pas fait pour le moment
l'objet de textes d'application
notamment pas de circulaire dans les
organismes sociaux et il ya encore pas
très longtemps j'avais saisi la
direction de la sécurité sociale en
disant il faut traduire ce droit à
l'erreur dans des instructions aux
responsables des caisses partout dans
les voiles à une une mesure
vous devrez y est préconisée est en tout
cas il est tout à fait clair que c'est
ça il faut que la personne qui de bonne
foi pas se tromper puisse c'est une
question de configuration du site
revenir en arrière et en tout cas ne pas
se voir imputer une pénalité
merci je donne la parole à monsieur
hamad à me berthe et pardon parce
qu'elle donne nous quitter assez
rapidement madame verte et je vous en
prie oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur le défenseur des
droits merci beaucoup pour cet exposé
très complet vous avez parlé
effectivement ça mon collègue a
précédemment posé une question sur les
msa et j'aimerais c'est un peu à celle
n'est pas se développer complètement ce
sujet ma préoccupation est la
transformation en effet sans maison
france service avec beaucoup d'exigence
alors qu'ils peuvent être une bonne
chose mais qui sont également
pénalisante notamment avec le nombre de
personnes présentes ce serait une bonne
chose qu'il y avait des subventions
suffisantes données en face aux
collectivités territoriales et sur un
temps un engagement de temps peut-être
plus l'on ne critique pas que cette
transformation en maison france service
ne soit pas suffisamment bien
d'accompagner et le concours est
pénalisante
et puis j'ai une deuxième question très
rapide
je pense aux schémas départementaux
d'accessibilité aux services publics
yatim les compilations une compilation
national de ces schémas départementaux
en avez-vous fait le bilan est ce cela
c'est une partie de votre rapport vous
remercie madame berthe et un suspense
service je rappelle que je je partage
exactement ce que vous dites par exemple
ça repose sur les collectivités
territoriales
est-ce que ça va pouvoir durer est ce
que dans les maisons france service
il y a les 9-10 service compétences qui
sont les serres et aidera jeu encore une
fois mon préjugé est favorable mais je
demande à voir
aujourd'hui il ya probablement moins de
1000 maisons
france services qui répondent
véritablement à tous les critères et
comme vous le dites très bien il faudra
que ça dure voilà quel est mon
mon sentiment sur la deuxième question
je ne crois pas qu'ils aient de
compilation nationale mais je ne peux
pas vous répondre
participent à cette visioconférence de
mes collaboratrices et notamment une
collaboratrice il s'appelle céline
jardot si je peux lui faire un appel et
ciel et si elle est est ce qu'elle est
capable de répondre à cette question à
ce que je dis est ce qu'il ya une
réponse à cette question est ce qu'il ya
une complication nationale des schémas
départementaux
alors bonjour il n'y a pas de
compilation il existe en service à la
mct qui récupère tous les schémas
départementaux qui a un tableau excel
qu'il est récapitule où il ya tout le
détail de ce qu'on comprend ce schéma
départemental mais il ya une étude est
une compilation pour savoir les ce qui
est vraiment réaliser c'est seulement
une collecte de tous les documents des
schémas départementaux
très bien merci beaucoup c'est lui voyez
la dame bertelli voilà une des
compositions que devra faire la mission
vous avez déjà un compte ouvert bombe
audition merci merci président hu a
devant moi c'est pour ça que je
m'attendais à ce qu'elle parle je la
vois une opération aussi souvent je suis
ravi de vous retrouver toujours en
pleine forme et merci pour votre exposé
vraiment très très intéressant.moi
justement j'ai une question par rapport
à l'union européenne
est ce que vous avez fait des
comparatifs
moi même j'ai fait un rapport sur tpe
pme et numérisation et donc je suis allé
au danemark a visité avec l'estonie et
ces deux pays sont très en avance
faites sur sur l'accès au numérique et
la dématérialisation et ce depuis très
longtemps et je me souviens dans ce que
j'avais entendu que même des personnes
les personnes âgées sont depuis très
longtemps en fait dans la
dématérialisation donc je voulais savoir
parce que moi je viens d'un je suis d'un
département de l'aisne où nous sommes
premiers pour l'hiver
guy lectrices mme et puis bien entendu
d'électro nisme un département dans les
plus pauvres donc aussi une difficulté
pour accompagner les personnes et
j'aurais voulu savoir aussi comment vous
vous impliquez l'éducation nationale est
ce qu'elle est vraiment prêt pour
préparer les jeunes pour l'avenir parce
que franchement l'électronique
aujourd'hui ça devient vous avez parlé
beaucoup des personnes handicapées mais
l'électronique devient un handicap et
enfin juste une dernière chose parce que
je me suis beaucoup impliqué dans
chômage dans l'allocation chômage
partiel est en fait il ya aussi des
problèmes de dimensionnement des plats
qui font qu'en fait il ya des bugs tout
le temps tout le temps et donc sa housse
qui ces emprunts en fait est que c'est
vraiment au niveau de l'administration
centrale qui ne pensent pas correctement
en fait les cahiers des charges pour la
mise à disposition et on a la même chose
sur le dmp où il ya un axe est
finalement très limité pour les
personnes merci monsieur tout - merci
monsieur le président sur le dernier
point c'est exactement ça rejoint tout à
fait mon observation le les sites mais
ce ne sont pas pensés pour les usagers
pour lesquels ils sont faits ni un ni en
nombre
n'ayant ni en qualité en ce qui concerne
l'éducation nationale vous avez
parfaitement raison
la la la crise depuis le le la fermeture
des écoles
le 12 mars a montré deux choses
elle a montré que tout de même le
système d'enseignement à distance
pouvait fin
né et que des millions et des millions
d'enfants et d'adolescents pouvaient en
bénéficier et coeur et que les
enseignants contrairement à des idées
souvent malheureusement un peu
péjorative avait été en majorité capable
d'assumer cette charge qui est ou même
très très difficile mais qu' il y avait
des problèmes naturellement d'équipement
et des problèmes de programme des verts
du côté d une question nationale
tout n'était pas prêt tout n'était pas
parfait
et puis surtout puis surtout comme vous
l'avez tous constaté que bien entendu
les gosses mêmes ou leur famille était
face à l'enseignement à distance dans
des situations d'inégalité dramatique et
j'ajoute que avec le déconfinement ça ne
fait que se poursuivre car toutes les
études l'ont démontré les enfants qui
sont où les ados qui sont revenus à
l'école au collège depuis quinze jours
ne sont pas hélas ceux qui avaient le
plus de difficultés tout le monde le
sait je pense que dans votre région vous
le savez vous savez aussi donc il y a
beaucoup de progrès en ce qui concerne
l'europe
nous sommes globalement c'est
l'impression que nous avons
naturellement sur ces questions un peu
décroché bien sûr par rapport à des pays
comme l'estonie est un pays en ligne
depuis il est lendemain de son
indépendance dans les années 95
c'est devenu un pays entièrement en
ligne
mais je voudrais là aussi me tourner
vers céline girardot est ce que dans
notre dans l'eau travaux est ce qu'on a
fait un peu une étude comparée par
rapport à d'autres à d'autres pays de
l'union européenne aux répondants madame
joli nom pour l'instant on n'a pas de
fait d'études mais l'as hautmont doit
répondre sur l'identité numérique on va
se baser sur notamment da
l'estonie et le danemark au pouvoir
apporter une réponse à l'édition du
défenseur oui je vais dans les réponses
écrites je vous le jeu je le dirai
davantage mais je pense globalement que
et là je fais un peu de deux de
philosophie et on l'a bien vu dans dans
ce qui a été fait ou ce qui est en train
d'être préparé vous allez discuter ici
quelques jours de l'application stop
qu'ovide au au sénat comme à l'assemblée
on est toujours dans une sorte de deux
sentiments ambigus dans un espèce de
paradoxes on voudrait pouvoir utiliser
toutes les facultés des nouvelles
technologies en particulier pour chez la
pandémie ou pour la réduire mais d'un
autre côté on est extrêmement soucieux
de ne pas entamer les libertés de ne pas
violer la vie privée
le secret médical par exemple et je j'ai
eu l'occasion mois à propos des deux
lois sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire de
donner des avis à l'assemblée au sénat
et de faire ce type d'observation
naturellement mais on constate
aujourd'hui par exemple vous l'avez
peut-être dans la presse encore ce matin
qu' il y a relativement peu de gens qui
entrent dans le système d' enquête qui a
été mis en place par la loi du 12 mai la
deuxième loi sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est qui et vous savez ce
système qu'on appelle entre 10 mai des
brigades parce que beaucoup de gens de
l'assurance maladie
10 mais finalement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui savent qu'ils sont porteurs du
virus mais qui pour diverses raisons ne
le disent pas et donc notre système ne
fonctionne pas puisque par définition il
est basé sur le volontariat
je dis ça parce que
on peut dire aujourd'hui les
circonstances sur dorna tic
il ya des questions de vie de mort mais
de manière générale sur l'accès au
numérique sur l'utilisation du numérique
on est vraiment dans la fameuse fable de
la langue d'esope et chacun intimement
chacun d'entre nous quelle que soit son
opinion politique quelle que soit sa
situation est pris entre cette idée que
ça peut être la meilleure des choses est
la pire est la pire des choses
et là je crois que les réponses ne peut
être apportée que par des politiques
publiques
kim est l'outil au service de tous et de
toutes
à égalité et puis ensuite chaque citoyen
avec sa liberté son autonomie
individuelle et son choix mais il faut
que tout le monde soit mis à égalité
pour pouvoir faire ce choix
merci alors qu'il reste trois questions
sur 7 rebonds nous avons et viviane
artigalas ensuite madame mama et pierre
cher et madame sophie tellier le pognon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de votre exposé aussi
très exhaustif est très intéressant moi
je voulais vous poser une question de
problème le plus tôt
j'avais auditionné lors d'une audition
interrogé le ministre cedrico sur mon
thème de dématérialisation en effet
depuis le 1er octobre 2018 les marchés
publics seront dématérialisés or les
très petites entreprises et les artisans
ont très souvent beaucoup de mal à
utiliser la plateforme dédiée et donc il
ne candidate plus sur ces marchés
publics jardins de proposer aux
ministres darmanin de le temps de
simplifier un petit peu tous deux formés
ces professionnels à l'utilisation de
cette plate-forme de retarder
de retarder la mise en oeuvre de cette
de rendre facultative c'est une
procédure de marché public le temps un
petit peu de mieux s'installer de façon
moins en moins sur chante pour pour ces
professionnels
bien sûr il n'avait répondu que non il n
était pas question donc je voulais
savoir si vous aviez vous même saisie de
ce problème parce que c'est un accès à
des marchés qui sont quand même
important pour ce faire particulier en
milieu rural pour ces petites et petites
entreprises
et puis si vous aviez été saisis aussi à
l'occasion de la crise c'est très
petites entreprises ces artisans avaient
eu du mal à avoir accès à leurs droits
s'ils étaient dématérialisés comme le
sont d'autres
d'autres procédures s'il avait eu du mal
si vous avez été c'est une difficulté de
ces petites entreprises et de ses
artisans avoir accès aux fonds de
solidarité par exemple pour les aider à
passer cette crise merci monsieur le
ministre on a eu quelques cas
effectivement de de tpe ayant des
difficultés notamment
vous venez d'en parler dans les
circonstances actuelles avec les avec
les banques
nuru le certains aux délégués ont fait
de l'âme de la médiation à ce sujet mais
la réponse à ce que vous avez dit à
monsieur darmanin et qui n'a pas accepté
c'est ce que j'ai dit à la fin de mon
propos il faut toujours maintenir une
voie traditionnelle une voie en papier
et de manière à ce que tout le monde
puisse y accéder et je pense que vous
allez avoir sûrement car beaucoup de
choses ne sont pas réglementaires
beaucoup de choses touche à des
principes et donc sont de niveau
législatif
je pense que vous allez avoir dans les
temps qui viennent dans les deux ans qui
viennent a examiné des textes qui
toucheront toutes ces questions je crois
qu'il faut que le sénat comme
l'assemblée soit
extrêmement intransigeant avec le avec
l'exécutif avec le gouvernement pour que
on n'arrête pas de mettre en place ces
procédures
je dirais à l'économie c'est à dire en
sachant à l'avancé qu'il y à un certain
pourcentage de personnes qui sont
concernées qui pourront en bénéficier
c'était évidemment l'est encore plus me
suis assis si si je me dis moi ce que tu
faisais quoi parle c'était moi c'était
moi ensuite il restait madame sophie
talipot lyon et le richert merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur
toubon pour toutes ces informations et
réflexions qui sont tout à fait
passionnante et on voit bien que c'est
là un sujet majeur pour pour le maintien
de l'état de droit
moi je m'intéressais justement je
m'interrogeais sur la façon dont on peut
dire que effectivement il ya des gains
de productivité évident pour les
services publics dans la
dématérialisation est que ces gains de
productivité doivent mettre doivent être
remis aux services de de l'accès delà de
l'amélioration de ses outils de
dématérialisation et de leur accès et
notamment les maisons de service public
les maisons de service public il y aura
a priori des agents qui seront des
agents extrêmement polyvalent moi ce qui
m'a ce qui m'interroge au delà de ça
c'est de vous dire avec la
multiplication des outils de
dématérialisation on arrive aussi à plus
grandes difficultés à gérer les cas
complexes
comment faire pour que si les moyens
sont mis davantage qui est très bien
pour je dirais gérer l'accès aux cas
simple c'est à dire remplir le
formulaire et pouvoir ainsi bénéficier
du l'accès aux services publics
mais pour la gestion des cas complexes
moi je crains que cette
dématérialisation en fait n'appauvrisse
énormément les services d'accueil et de
renseignements plus compliqué et qu'on
est
une difficulté à un moment donné à avoir
tout simplement à un être humain soit en
face de soi sont au téléphone quand on
est dans une situation difficile en c et
vous disiez fort bien que des logiciels
sont fait souvent parce qu'ils ne les
remplit spa est donc parfois sont un
petit peu en tombe un petit peu dans une
bureaucratie kafkaïenne avec des cas on
se dit voilà je ne rentre pas dans la
case
donc comment faire que des moyens soient
conservés pour une gestion humaine des
cas complexes des gars qui ne sont pas
prêts liés qui représente certes une
faible proportion de toutes les dossiers
à traiter mais qui peuvent se révéler
être de véritables cauchemars pour les
pour les usagers du service public qui y
sont confrontés sur madame vous parlez
de or nous avons depuis que étudiants
ces questions me au centre de nos
préoccupations
l'absence de dialogue que l'utilisation
de la dématérialisation introduit dans
la relation entre l'usagé et le service
public
quand vous allez à un guichet vous avez
en face de vous monsieur oldham auquel
vous pouvez poser des questions
auxquelles qui normalement va vous
répondre
auquel vous pouvez tout simplement
tendre un formulaire et lui dire madame
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça est-ce
qu'il faut cocher cette case ou est-ce
qu'il faut cocher cette case est ce que
ça veut dire est ce que dans ma
situation je dois remplir cette case ou
noir en perd 7,4
c'est la même chose quand vous êtes au
téléphone au téléphone classique vous
avez la possibilité de dialoguer ce que
vous dites très bien est ce que nous
avons dénoncé c'est que le système tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui est assez de
dématérialisation est un système
unilatérales c'est à dire dans lequel
l'usager à un certain moment ça arrive
très souvent il a planté où il aura une
proposition une question une case auquel
il ne comprendra pas ce qu'il faut
répondre
il le fera
au petit bonheur la chance et on va se
retrouver dans la situation de l'erreur
dont on parlait tout à l'heure avec
monsieur gold donc je pense que une des
mesures que la mission d'information
doit impérativement à mon avis préconisé
c'est naturellement le retour de
l'humain et je vous donne un exemple je
parlais tout à l'heure de la prime
d'activité qui a bien fonctionné mais je
prends un autre exemple on se plaint
toujours beaucoup des services des
finances
on se plaint beaucoup de ce que la
direction générale des finances
publiques est en train de regrouper son
dispositif notamment dans les
départements ruraux ou semi-ruraux au
supprime ce qu'on appelait dans les
temps anciens les perceptions les
trésoreries et on remplace par un
certain nombre de points d'accès qui
vont être pu réduit en nombre mais où
les personnes qui ont des peuls faire
des formalités qui ont des problèmes
pour accéder à de l'information et pour
en discuter
n'diaye peut-être ont-elles le faire par
téléphone
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que j'ai
trouvé que la direction générale des
finances publiques et oui je le dis de
manière tout à fait innocente parce
qu'en général ces deux de bonheur de bon
aloi de taper sur le dos des finances je
pense que la direction générale des
finances publiques a pris les choses
dans le bon sens elle a bien vu que l
avait un problème d'implantation donc
ces implantations vont être réduites
elle va les remplacer par d'autres au
même endroit où dans d'autres endroits
en nombre plus réduit et ces nouvelles
implantations vont rendre des services
qui seront dans beaucoup de cas appuyé
sur une présence humaine une présence
humaine physique ou une présence humaine
téléphonique
j'ai lu deux ou trois départements que
j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter et à
chaque fois
moi je
intéresse naturellement à ces questions
puisque c'est mon boulot l'accès aux
services publics
j'ai eu deux ou trois départements dans
lesquels la direction départementale des
finances publiques a à mon avis réussi
la reconversion en quelque sorte des
services et où les mères qui était
extrêmement anxieux bien entendu et même
furieux de voir disparaître les
perceptions les trésoreries se déclarent
aujourd'hui relativement satisfaits du
système qui est mis en place
c'est qu'une réponse humaine et je crois
madame taillé et poli ans que c'est ça
le là aussi les recommandations
c'est le retour de l'humain avec les
économies avec les économies que la
dématérialisation au cur et elles sont
incontestables eh bien il faut pouvoir
dans les sous préfectures dans certains
services publics dans certains
organismes sociaux dans les maisons
france service installer des agents de
l'état et pas seulement des agents payés
par les collectivités territoriales
parce que les collectivités
territoriales elles ont bon dos mais il
ya un jour où elles ne pourront plus et
donc je crois que vous avez touché un
point très important
l'humain merci monsieur pinault enfin
dernière question majeure
merci
président mais c'est tout bon je termine
l'audition donc beaucoup a été dit je
voudrais revenir sur sur deux points
vous avez évoqué je me semble-t-il 13
millions de personnes aujourd'hui qui
serait concerné par par l'électronicien
je voulais savoir si ce chiffre était en
augmentation ou stables par rapport par
rapport à la pris à la prise de
conscience de ce qu'est l'électro nisme
parce que ça ne date pas ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
malheureusement puisque quand on remonte
dans les années antérieures dès 1999 un
premier ministre de l'époque et met tout
le monde en garde en disant qu'il
fallait pas qu'il est qd ronis mme
deviennent l'avatar de l'illettrisme un
donc donc voilà où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui je pense que malheureusement
les décennies ont passé et on est
toujours dans cette notion d'électro
nisme la crise sanitaire a entraîné une
accélération considérable de l'entrée
dans le numérique que ce soit pour la
médecine avec la téléconsultation que ce
soit au niveau d'éducation nationale
comme ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure
pour pour nos jeunes comme pour le
télétravail ne pensez vous pas que cette
accélération que laissait encore plus de
personnes sur le côté alors que cela
peut être une chance pour beaucoup de
nos territoires ruraux je suis du
département du cher voilà est-ce qu'on
va pas avoir des personnes qui vont qui
vont entrer dans cette forme d'électro
nisme parce que c'est tellement vague
que je pense que chacun a un moment dans
son parcours de vie est un électro nist
donc voilà est-ce que cette fracture
sociale
cet isolement si je pense notamment aux
ehpad aux ehpad ou les personnes ont été
ont été confinés avec les entre
guillemets les dégâts que l'on peut
connaître
on a vu aussi que le numérique pouvait
rompre l'isolément
je pense que ce sont toutes ces
questions qui se posent à nous pour les
années à venir mais mais trouvez vous
qu'entre le moment où on a posé la
question et aujourd'hui il y a eu
suffisamment d'avancé pour les c2
de l'espoir et enfin je terminerais pour
le parle parce numérique parce qu'il ya
quelques années certains avaient demandé
à augmenter le nombre d'heures pour les
publics
je crois qu'il était de 20 heures ils
demandaient jusqu'à 28 eur je crois que
ça fait un angle de de la même façon
savoir savoir où nous en sommes merci
monsieur toubon marché c'est très
difficile peut-être de deux d'estimer
quelle est la part de la population qui
peut être qualifié de populations en
difficulté face aux formalités numérisés
face à l'heure à la numérisation
on peut mesurer comme je lé fais tout à
l'heure par exemple les communes de
l'est cali a pas du tout internet ou à
l'internet heures insuffisant on peut
voir combien il ya d'habitants
là on peut mais je pense que la
meilleure mesure plus activement la
meilleure vision ce sujet c'est que
quelle que soit l'évolution de cette
population elle probablement légèrement
en croissance ce qui est en cause c'est
le développement à grande digue
et comme je les dis dans mon rapport à
marche forcée de la dématérialisation de
certaines procédures de certains
services publics sans se préoccuper
d'eux quelle est la situation en face de
ces millions de personnes et la bonne
toute façon on est sûr que la situation
et c'est tout l'objet de mon rapport je
dirais on est sûr que la situation s'est
dégradée et qu' il y à des situations
aujourd'hui d'inégalités croissantes ont
d'être humains au détriment des
personnes qui ne peut pas accéder à ces
formalités et on l'a vu
bien entendu de manière spectaculaire ça
a été rendue visible pendant la crise de
lakovic 19 depuis le mois février et le
mois de mars
puisqu'on a bien vu comment il y avait
un certain nombre de personnes qui
étaient exclus et la seule façon de
traiter ça c'est de construire tous les
systèmes en fonction des personnes les
plus éloignées et non pas en fonction
des personnes expertes et deuxièmement
c'est comme on sait que de toute façon
il y aura des centaines les centaines de
milliers de personnes qui auront des
difficultés de prévoir les formules de
recours et d'accompagnement de manière à
faire face à ces situations
je crois que il y à une sorte 2
il ya une sorte d'examen de conscience
qu'il faut que les pouvoirs publics
qu'ils soient de l'état soit des
collectivités territoriales ou des
organismes de protection sociale
il ya une sorte d'examen de conscience
qu'il faut faire
est ce que quand on lance ce type de
réforme
est ce que quand on la conçoit on se
regarde on réfléchit est-ce que j'ai
bien poser la question de toutes les
personnes qui vont se trouver impactés
par ce nouveau système est ce que je me
suis bien poser la question est ce que
j'ai donné les bonnes réponses pour que
tout le monde puisse l'utiliser c'est
une question je dirais deux philosophies
politiques de psychologie politique
véritablement qui est mise en cause et
je suis moi plutôt optimiste c'est à
dire je crois que les pouvoirs publics
de manière générale ferons le nécessaire
mais il y a c'est pour ça que votre
mission est très importante
il y à l'audience
encore une fois l'agenda 2022 c'est tout
à fait demain matin demain matin et et
que bien entendu on a eu plusieurs mois
de retard malheureusement avec la crise
sanitaire
il peut y avoir d'autres occasions qui
crée d'autres difficultés peut-être
moins dramatique mais qui créeront des
retards il faut absolument que le
gouvernement présente et je serai co
si elle était engagée justement devant
la conférence nationale du handicap au
mois de janvier présente un véritable
plan constitué nourrit extrêmement
important pour remettre de l'humain en
sorte que tous les systèmes toutes les
réformes soient configurés à destination
des personnes susceptibles d'avoir le
plus de difficultés pour y accéder et
non pas pour celles qui n'auront jamais
aucun aucun problème voilà c'est une
question véritablement de moyens bien
sûr mais aussi de philosophie du service
public
en france le service public c'est la
voix qui il ya d'autres moyens d'accéder
aux droits en france c'est le service
public
si le service public ne permet pas
d'accéder à égalité pour tous ça veut
dire il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui seront discriminés dans
leur accès au droit
merci beaucoup monsieur thibault pour
cette audition que vous avez su rendre
riche attrayante captivante passionnante
jeu pardon monsieur le président j'avais
prévu j'avais trop bu
vous m'avez pas vu voilà je vous prie de
m'excuser dont je vous ai pas vu mille
excuses
non mais c'est pas grave j'ai été
déconnecté pendant un petit moment
je voulais juste poser une question donc
on s'était déjà rencontré monsieur
toubon lors de la loi et c'est ce que
parce que j'avais un amendement
justement sur
le droit à l'erreur et surtout chez
indispensable à maintenir et ne pensez
vous pas avec la crise que nous avons
vécue et notamment pour ce qui concerne
je peux pas vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure
l'éducation et les inégalités criantes
qui sont en train de de surgir sur la
question du matériel informatique dans
les familles malheureusement il n'y
avait pas d'ordinateur pour tout le
monde et parfois pas d'ordinateur du
tout comme vous l'avez mentionné
est-ce que ça n'est pas et c'était ma
question est ce que ça n'est pas sur le
principe de l'accès à tous de service
public numérisés
est ce qu'il n'ya pas la question du
matériel qui va être une des grandes
questions à l'avenir puisque justement
le matériel évolue beaucoup évoluent
vite une famille par exemple qu'un peu
de moyens qui investit dans un
ordinateur qui au bout de deux ans
chauffer et n'est plus n'est plus
opérationnel va avoir du mal à
réinvestir de l'argent parce que
justement ce matériel
sabine entre guillemets très vite et
n'est plus à disposition
est ce qu'il ne frappe une fois pas
après iliad évidemment les maisons
services au public mais ça n'est pas
très pratique et pour le coup pendant le
confinement pour les élèves pour les
enfants ça n'était pas accessible du
tout je l'espère la question du matériel
informatique ne va pas se poser
c'était ma question je remercie je pense
je pense qu'il faut il faut se situer
dans les deux cas ce qu'estime la
perspective d'une période normale disons
qu'il est pas la crise que nous vivons
actuellement et dans laquelle il faut
incontestablement que comme je les
dictateurs nous ayons la possibilité de
compléter la dématérialisation par des
voies alternatives et par
l'accompagnement est cuit dans des
périodes de crise comme celle que nous
connaissons
c'est là effectivement le cas parler de
manière plus criante
li ning
l'idée entre ceux qui disposent de
moyens et ceux qui ne disposent pas là
le défenseur des droits tu peux
difficilement s'exprimer parce que c'est
naturellement une question de choix de
politiques publiques mais on peut
s'interroger sur le point de savoir si
l'éducation à distance n'étant pas de
toute façon en train de se développer là
le la tâche de l'état ou des
collectivités territoriales lorsqu'elles
sont compétentes ne serait pas de donner
à chaque enfant et à chaque famille
les moyens d'y accéder et notamment à
travers des ordinateurs les plus anciens
dont je fais parti savent très bien ce
qui s'est fait dans les années 70
lorsqu'il y avait des plans calcul
lorsque il y avait des plans ou re dans
les années 80 fournir des ordinateurs
dans toutes les écoles ont à l'époque
beaucoup de gens ont vu ses politiques
ses tentatives comme en quelque sorte
anecdotique et aujourd'hui on se rend
compte qu'en fait c'est un problème qui
est au coeur de la société donc vous
posez madame préville
c'est une vraie question je suis donc il
n'y a plus de question
c'est ici en corée
sinon puisque non alors je me propose de
mettre un terme à cette visioconférence
en vous réitérant monsieur toubon tous
nos remerciements et parce que cette
visioconférence était une séance nous
avons beaucoup appris et beaucoup
apprécié votre intervention à mes
collègues je donne rendez-vous l'as roma
dès demain puisqu'il ya une nouvelle
vision conférence à partir de 15 heures
autour de monsieur jean-marc mériaux
directeur du numérique de l'éducation
merci à toutes et à tous merci beaucoup
cominar est bon travail à la mission bon
travail article ils sont masqués me
voilà pour cette audition du défenseur
des droits jacques toubon devant les
sénateurs
autour de l'électronique ou
l'illettrisme numérique
un phénomène qui concerne 17 % de la
population française
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous à 18h
pour notre émission de débat et
l'analyse
allant plus loin présenté par rebecca
fitoussi très bonne soirée sur public
sénat
[Musique]
je